john's wood jugeant ce coup sûr un trail
3 et beaucoup de gens aux alentours
notamment à ma gauche il ya je ne sais
même pas ce quiz et excusez moi parce
que dark funeral en fait c'est sa petite
vidéo en même temps pendant lequel écran
il explique ce qu'on va faire
alors une question d j'ai envie de
passer de la cty ciel on va jouer
saboteurs qui coince moins une classe
assaut alors c'est parti ou c'est un ami
c'est un ami s'appelle malak 64 allez
viens viens fait fut bien allez hop
alors ça va bien a voulu trop ne sais
pas non plus mais c'est pas grave
alors écoutez on n'a fait qu'une partie
en multi le haut il améliorer ma santé
maximum ces jeunes il ya du monde on va
lancer je te la dit mme sheeran j'arrive
tiens accroche-toi la vie tient à tokyo
une seringue dans le sol même pas sur
toi y en ait mis ses jauges au 6e jour6e
jojo jojo ne crie pas trop fort s'il te
plaît on va ranimer l'autre je suis
manche mort dans le baïkal à aa à aa pas
croyable bon on y retourne
mais c'était dave c'était dégueulasse
sujet alors c'est du team deathmatch
pour savoir au niveau des armes il ya un
an et demi qui vient de sauter là bas
tout droit on va essayer d'anticiper ce
qui va faire en lançant une grenade ce
qu'est ce qui va venir
oui on l'a touché oui c'est moi il est
mort ça a très bien marché
bravo or c'était d'ailleurs elle perd
coach sétois d'ailleurs c'est pas top
bassetto a d'ailleurs alors c'est parti
on va continuer on a une master tive
dtcc doucement va essayer de voir si ya
pas d ennemis il ya fut là bas puis fut
tu fus viendra bien là bien ça va bien
et toi
saint vallier saint vallier saint alyre
malaxe ces malades fait attention ça
arrive à de l'autre côté du village
livephone du coup de l'autre côté
bon c'est un espèce de colo version far
cry on voit trop mal c'est fun cas
graves commenté au bien joué elle vague
en tout cas graphiquement c'est joli
annoncé comme jordan quand jordan qui
avait la grosse maîtrise lourde bon on
va prendre reprendre le sénat on va
camper au sniper comme des [ __ ] legros
campeurs à la lourde il s'appelle yann
ou 91 et nous fait les finger eaux du
sud les grand merci à tous et gratuit
manac pas attention
malak malak par histoire énorme par
contre quand tu scoop tu te déplaces est
de valeur et la centriste atwell change
chiant boom et schott c'était moi on va
camper ici rien ça marche plutôt bien
oh la balle est un mec bien spot second
klinger au dessus de l'écran merci à new
yok yok monabanq à tolosa arrive dans la
maison malak mac os x quitte je m'en
fous je me comporte nigh part je me
comporte leiber j'en ai un à un vers
niamey qui montre le montagner de ce
bonhomme aux bâtards
mais avec de la montagne un mec dans la
montagne dont l'animation est un petit
peu relou
allez go sport double jo c'est le bac tu
es mort dès le bac montre toi mais parce
que ce n'est pas rentré la maman
et la fraise
genevois lamine diallo j'ai eu beau
petit doigt il voit l'ami il fait mal
elle perco buck à temps j'aimerais bien
jouer au shotgun moi c'est où
si ses larmes secondaire du sprinter
annoncé un nouveau tube génial on va
jouer lance grenade genre ouais c'est
[ __ ] mais c'est plutôt lent
effectivement on va pas se mentir c'est
dégueulasse à faire aux attendes il ya
des copieurs j'ai lancé un cocktail
mais genre espère qu tu est invincible
tu as entre et un cheat codes d'ubisoft
alors tout le monde est témoin elle
perco est un twitter et je joue est un
campeur aaa mais c'est de la triche
il ya pierre flabbée y en ad'autres côté
là
et toi friel j'étais caché qu'un vieux
ce texte est vu à travers la personne
ouais voilà comment un but de ce texte
est énorme
restez pas vraiment alors je rejette la
composent tu m'as fait peur pas
m'emballer coucheurs warriors emmerde je
me suis dit ça me tombe dessus
tiens d'élevage au tac ouvert mon bac
merci y'a un mec là bas au fond
albert crocheter vu l perco
au sujet des avants du bon beaucoup
d'émotion
on lance grenade n'est pas très efficace
d'un côté ils m'ont ganga de les [ __ ]
bien joie de fêter où elle diffuse de
suite tu fus la phrygie elle tout là-bas
la frij elle remettre lui thomas août
merde merde à bien ouej choisi moi aussi
bien qu'en personnel chez moi je fais
campagne peur comme dans sa longue robe
à la fenêtre
lui qui était à la fenêtre c'est pas
tous les codes jordan ianu je peux y
avait quelqu'un à la fenêtre là est ce
qu'il peut y retourner
waouh et jojo et chat
c'est pas mal ça la lp recours est
chaude
tu comme avec moi ouais haut qu'en bas
deux au attention on est pris en chasse
well et eagle has de vue quand tu es
dans ton dans son fief
oumou y en a qui va faire le tour bien
ouej ali badjo on va les couilles
j'aime quand c'est qu'en fait c'est la
vie histoire à tanger en effet le string
non ah bah non
et alors et alors
non mais non mais non mais non fm ckoi
touche masters alors tout bon est en
train de ranger sur moi actuellement
parce que je comme comme une vieille
[ __ ] et elle va comme à détrôner
c'était épique
moi je vous tourner c'était génial là
par contre je joue tu me pique à ma
place
richmond joliff master kids je crois que
j'te vois pas en faire mal
ouais il tente des choses elle perco
merde au nom la sécurité à la cheville
et quoi tu secoues mais elle est
vraiment ignoble quoi oh c'est moi je
suis en train de mettre un bandage
riel tué 2 j allais dans ce top abrégé
douthat évolué mais il faut trouver le
juste de spots de la cabane il est pas
mal ouais quand tu voyais ça par contre
c'est normal quand tu scoop la
sensibilité elle est vraiment ignoble
ouais ouais
1 ouais ouais mais s'il faut à bouaye
voilà ça deviens pro bike est bloqué
mais c'est un ennemi merde bah je sais
pas c'est aléatoire t ou à je te vois
j'arrive fut well as tu en fais chier on
va aller au spot on va faire rage et
enfin jean
sessùn sonne
allez vous faire [ __ ]
vous n'êtes pas humain vous êtes est
plus qu'un d'animaux c'est ça que vous
êtes dépasse nos jours